some days you run some days you walk
just make sure you're moving forward
every day it's my book writing day and
last week I tried riding from starbucks
and walking to the starbucks and running
back and it worked out great and i
thought hey you know what i'm going to
try this again there's a problem though
you hear the wind picking up last night
idence morning there was this crazy
thunderstorm the remnants are still here
with this crazy wind I was a bright
sunny day I went to bed at five in the
morning waking up tossing and turning
going back to bed and I woke up at eight
thirty so I'm not functional a lot of
sleep today and it could have been super
easy for me to say I'm tired you know
I'm not I'm not feeling like going to
starbucks I'm not going to go there and
just cashing the day but it's important
to remember that some days you run and
some days you walk just make sure you're
moving forward every single thing and I
think a lot of people just find excuses
for not getting stuff done say well it's
not the perfect timing and it's never
the perfect time and it's like saying is
a perfect timing to have a baby right
it's never the perfect timing you can
always find something some reason for
you not to go and do the uncomfortable
thing the thing that you need to do to
help grow your business so that's the
message for today some days you run some
days you walk some days maybe you crawl
but just make sure you're moving forward
every single day ok so it's Q a time
last week I went on a rant saying how
all you guys want to talk about was my
beard and I wanted questions and now you
guys delivered the game be questions in
out of that beard back don't worry it's
not going to get to the epic stage it
was not before so here are your
questions
please stop
one of the downsides of recording with
an ipad what I realized is that it stops
recording I didn't notice so I'm just
answering questions as I'm walking to
the starbucks and none of them recorded
because I was tapping out to go to the
Evernote file I see them in and then
coming back so I'm pissed off I don't
want to answer them again right now
maybe on the way back maybe next week's
episode we'll see i'm going to get the
starbucks thank you guys for the support
i promise i will get to those questions
at some point believe and i'll see you
soon ok so the walk calm me down a
little bit I'm close to the starbucks
and is this little park that's along the
way I thought I'd pull in and quickly
answer the questions a second time
because the first time we didn't work
and you know the last name Carmichael we
have our own in crest and under the
crust it says to jeweled crack which is
French for always ready so like a good
Carmichael i also have all the questions
print it out here that i'm going to go
through [ __ ] i'm going to go faster
they did before because I feel like I've
really done this before the first
question jarhead six cool shoes bro
thank you sir we're using your iPad
follow-up from sensei Ryan I'd like to
notice as well the sound was really good
who are we using for the sound all I'm
doing is using my iPad have the camera
facing towards me and you'll flip it and
then when I'm walking I'm just holding
it out like this with two hands that's
not a shaky and now I'm just resting on
a park bench that's it sounds decent
it's a little bit windier today so I
guess we'll see how the auto turns out
when I when I film normally I live on a
long street before you get to the main
street so it's typically pretty quiet
and I'll film there the Q&A part so that
long as much background noise but now
I'm closer to the main street so I don't
know we'll see how it works out another
question since a Ryan speaking of the
book have you ever considered speaking
to an audio player didn't happen someone
transcribe it for you from here you can
edit it so basically the rough draft
would be read instead of written what
are your thoughts believe I love that
and I wish I could do that my biggest
challenge with that is I'm a much better
writer than I am a speaker speaking I'm
not fantastic
off the cuff unless I am just super
passionate and excited about something
in the moment but typically I'm a more
reserved thoughtful I think about what I
say before I say it to the most part and
I'm just a much better writer than I am
a talker so it makes more sense even
though I'm not a few Tran of the process
to write it down instead of just talking
but I I appreciate the love I'm feeling
the love thank you so much since they
Ryan for the suggestion next up stike 96
talking about scheduling because I talk
about scheduling last week when she was
schedules that I can't seem to have set
schedules for the week because I have
loads of random things popping up all
the time so just going out somewhere or
something my dad wants help with stuff
like that is there any way to set a
schedule and a lifestyle where things
just pop where things pop up like that
also you don't do something one day
wouldn't affect all the following days
is everything would have to move down a
day until now I don't have set timings
are things but I'd love to hear your
thoughts about the topic this fantastic
i have a lot of thoughts on scheduling
i'll try to keep it brief ah
specifically to this i believe been
running a no prices business and I know
crisis life as much as possible I hate
putting out fires I hate being
reactionary mode I hate always having to
just respond the thing instead of being
proactive instead of managing my time
protecting my time which isn't important
to me and training the people in my life
and in my business to respect my time as
well it starts with you respecting your
time first though and so I've hired
people who can take on projects instead
of tasks i have set time for things
where people know not to distract me
unless it's super-important right I
don't have a cell phone at all I don't
have data on my iPad I don't have a
phone at the office except an answering
machine that's it you know I don't want
people calling it's funny my book agent
saying but what's your cell number in
case in case you know there's an issue
that i need to get hold of you said well
I don't have a cell phone and she's
blown away that I don't have a cell
phone I
anyway it's because I want to run a no
crisis business I told her the problem
with having a cell phone is that people
call you and I don't want other people
calling me on my time because
unscheduled phone calls is one of the
biggest distractions that you have in
your life and so I choose not to have
them in my life and for emergencies I
have facebook open so that that's my
go-to if you're if you're my friend my
family you're on my facebook friend
Paige I'm on there all the time and if
there's ever an emergency that's the
fastest way to reach me but again my
friends like my family know not to
disturb me during the day because i'm
busy working so you have to set rules
you have to set boundaries you have to
not always be in reactionary mode and
and that has saved so much of my time
and my energy and allows me to get a lot
of stuff done in terms of what happens
if you if you fall off track one day
what happened to the next day for me
what i do is i have different dates for
different things so you know tuesdays my
writing day whens is my video day
Thursday's my meeting day today is my
writing day if you know if I don't get
my writing done because something
happens you know some huge emergency
then I don't do writing for that week I
don't let that fall into the rest of my
week and I try as much as possible to
like I said at the start of the show you
run you walk and then if needed you
crawl right I don't want to lose the
entire day so you know I'm a little
tired today I won't get as much writing
as I normally do on a tuesday but i'm
still going to get some done right and i
don't let that bleed into the rest of
the week next question carbide show 1
hey Evan which job or industry is good
for students from Europe to obtain as
much possible experience in Canada
listen I want to answer questions about
the book and what I'm talking about in
the last episode but i'll i'll be nice
on this one you know this is a standard
answer the industry that you want to get
into is the one where you are most
passionate about the one we're going to
provide the most value to the one that
makes you come alive and you're excited
about don't look for a job don't look
for ministry don't look to start a
business in a field that you think you
can make a lot of money and/or have
success with its it's not going to work
the best way is to find something that
you are excited about and you love doing
and
for the opportunities will open
themselves up to you there's a bunch of
schools in Canada that you can work with
where you come as an intern I've had a
number of students in turn up my company
from other countries and and they get
work experience in Canada because you
can only be here for so long without the
right pieces and I've end up hiring a
lot of those people looking to while
with my business so I think it'll work
but again follow your passion Dante
surprise the gardens worn them for only
five years and forever hahaha Dante love
my five fingers I used to I used to have
bad backs I just have bad knees and it
was debilitating like in my 20s I had
terrible knees and a bad back then i sat
at a computer all day long and the two
things that changed when i use a
stand-up desk which really helped and
two I were these vibrams as much as
possible not always possible in in
Toronto Canada actively have winter and
I can't get my feet into the winter
version of these things maybe I'll try
again this year but literally saved my
knees save my back almost no problems
anymore and vibrams and sand of Desmond
a big fan next 0 2 337 755 that that's
the youtube name of the day hey man what
are your thoughts are negative family
friends more importantly when they act
like you need to prove yourself to them
so I've talked a lot about having a
supportive environment if you want to
achieve great things you have to have a
great environment right and and the
problem is just like the schedule too
many people are reactionary in their
environment you are reactionary to the
friends and family in your life and the
media you consume and your daily routine
in your schedule we're now you have to
take control we have to be in charge it
to be proactive and if your friends and
your family aren't supportive of what
you do then you have to go create new
friends right you got to surround
yourself with people who want to build
you up who see greatness in you you want
to achieve great things you need to be
surrounded by great ideas and great
people and people will make that
greatness come out not that people hold
you back not the little man in your life
okay in terms of the expectations this
is a really important decision and this
is something that a lot of people don't
necessarily do but you have to decide if
you are going to live your version of
your life or someone else's version of
your life you know they tell you know
you can't do it it's not possible
not get you fired up that's fuel for you
to go and do it right if somebody tells
me that it's not possible your big dream
can't happen you're never going to be
able to do this that lights a fire on
the right that gets me excited that
makes me want to go out and do it that
it gives me drive and energy but if it's
if it's that people have these
expectations of you to do something that
you don't want to do right like you're
supposed to join the family business are
you supposed to go be a doctor or a
lawyer or a dentist or an accountant or
whatever and that's not what you want to
do and you feel you need to live up to
them you got it you got to release
yourself from the chains because you are
not living your life you're living
somebody else's version of your life and
you're never going to achieve great
things you're never going to be really
happy you're never going to be a
massively productive citizen of your
community if you're not doing things
that make you come alive when you're
excited by so you have to make the
mental shift right now to say I'm living
my version of my life and not someone
elses version of my life and when you
make that shift things start to happen
next up hey Evan what are some examples
of research into your book just curious
to know some seek information of what
could may appear in the book X Naruto
one thank you for the book question much
appreciated so in the book I'm outline a
lot of strategies of I views and I've
seen helped me grow my business and it's
help the businesses of people around me
what I want to do now with the book is
show how you can apply these strategies
to grow a business to various stages so
I'm interviewing a guy who use my
strategies to get to $50,000 full time
income business right respectable
doesn't have to have a job anymore then
a company that's taking it to quarter
million then the cover is taking it to 1
million then a company is taking it to 5
million their company's taken to 150
million so no matter where you want the
spectrum no matter where you want the
growth path these strategies can work
just the application of them are
slightly different depending on where
you are on your path and so what I've
been doing is interviewing people on my
channel with the hangouts if you go back
to look at some of the hangers to see
some interviews
but now we've got to do more research on
them to see if they're justified to be
in the book and I have to understand
more about their business and their
philosophies because I can only pull out
so much in half an hour so an example
let me pull it out here this is mission
mission in a bottle Seth Goldman and
Seth Goldman has a company called
honesty they sell natural very low sweet
teas and hundreds of millions of dollars
in sales they told her business the
coca-cola Seth Goldman's a founder I
interviewed him on my channel we can
link that up as a google hangout you
know I don't know if I'm going to
include him in the book or not like I
got to do a little more research it
could be he could have one page in the
book or he could have a chapter in the
book and so I have to understand more
about him and so he wrote a book and so
I should read the book right this is
actually a pretty cool book if you look
at it it's his story but it's all told
in comic book form at comic book format
so I've never seen a book like that in
the hardcover hardcover version I took
off the jacket so it's easier to travel
with and I won't get a damaged I don't
have a set time in my schedule to read I
read blogs and I read news and I read my
feeds on feedly but I don't have a set
time to weep books and you know being an
author it's good to read books and to do
research and so on my walk here it takes
out 40 minutes what I usually do is
start recording my interest to your
questions and then I start reading the
books and all you know right notes and
I'll fold the pages and so I have
something to go back to so thank you the
question that's what I'm doing and then
the last one was ten jeep i hope i
pronounced that right the schedule is
good you're right to follow the flow
good luck on the book Thank You Tanji I
appreciate the good luck and that's it
for this week so i'm here at the
starbucks i'm almost there i'm going to
write i hope i have a fantastic day I
hope you have a fantastic day run walk
crawl but make sure you're moving
forward every single day thank you guys
for watching you have a question that
you want me to answer next week make it
related to the book or book writing
process or something I talked about
today that'd be much appreciated leaving
the comments below I'll see you guys
next week continue to
lean